curious thing happened this morning some
of you I've had a chance to tell about
but soon after we opened today I got a
call from someone who sounded extremely
credible to me I didn't have any reason
to doubt it who said that they were
calling on behalf of Eric Alterman and
he was so apologetic he felt really bad
but he was extremely ill and was not
able to come today and that we would
have to cancel the event and I was quite
concerned and talked to the person for
quite a while and we talked about his
recent media appearances and seemed to
be quite knowledgeable and so when we
hung up I called c-span and told them he
wasn't going to be here they cancelled
the crew and then within an hour the
publisher called back and said that's
odd we emailed him earlier today and he
didn't say anything about being ill
turned out it was a complete hoax
so we'll see what is what does that mean
we can only yeah I wish we had caller ID
so that's the preliminary to tonight's
event well as if many if not most of you
or all of you know that Eric Alterman is
the media columnist for the nation and
MSNBC comm and he has been a
contributing editor or columnist for
worth Rolling Stone L Mother Jones in
the London Sunday express educated at
Cornell Yale and Stanford he was
recently named one of the 50 best most
important and most influential
journalists on the Internet
he is the author of sound and fury the
making of the honey say that pundit talk
Christie he and lives in Manhattan but
the book that he'll be talking about
tonight is what liberal media the truth
about bias and the news please welcome
Eric Alterman
thank you thanks for coming
I love it when they have you waited in
the lesbian erotica section you almost
lost me friend yeah somebody stole my
aunt Coulter line huh
I mean you kissed a girl once and look
what happened
not a little weird like I thought you
know since I'm in LA I actually thought
about it was it was karmic this thing
that happened cuz it's been kind of
strange the Karma that's been following
me around on this trip since I started
in Seattle I was on the started to snow
when I was in the airport in New York
and we just got out um and then you know
here I have this weird phone call
cancelling the thing for apparently a
very nice woman and um in San Francisco
the other night relax I guess this was
Berkeley it was an audience very very
much like this one and I started to
speak and a very nicely dressed older
man just stood up and said you're a dick
and and walked out and it reminded me a
couple weeks ago I was in I was on
vacation for a weekend in Miami Beach
and I was in the hotel bar and the
Challenger blew up and everybody's
watching it and we had the TV on dan
Rather and I don't know if any of you
saw this but um you know the the TV
stations are so desperate at times like
that they'll if you call them up and say
I'm I'm I'm somebody they'll put you on
right away without any thing so they put
some guy on who said he was an
eyewitness to the explosion this is true
I'm not making this up and and he
started described they said welcome
describe the scene and the guy says yeah
I'm walking around now I'm on my cell
phone oh look there's a tooth of one of
the astronauts and he said this live on
the air and and then rather realized
that he he had someone who shouldn't be
on the air and he said well we have to
go now and and thank you
you know that uh that commercial I mean
that when you go to the movies now and
that button goes off in the guy's anyway
so where was it so rather is he realized
that's the kid got off the phone and and
go back to the you know the rest of the
sane world and um and so he says thank
you very much and he starts to hang up
on the guy and the guy says and you're
an idiot and and give Dan Rather credit
he comes back on the air he says well I
am an idiot
but that's not relevant right now and so
I'm here to say well I am a dick but
that guy couldn't have known it usually
is this a little weird cuz I'm talking
to c-span but I'm talking to you like
c-span isn't really real at the moment
anyway and and when I when I speak to
audiences about the book it's a
different kind of talk then and then I
give when I'm on say bill o'reilly or
something because the people come see me
don't really need to have the fact that
there is no liberal media explain to
them they basically understand that and
that's why they're sufficiently
enthusiastic don't want to hear more
about it so i I want to talk a little
bit I want to you know we can you can
ask me when I'm done oh by the way Eric
you forgot to mention why the media is
not really liberal if I don't actually
get that covered but I want to go off
the topic a little bit because one thing
I don't do a very good job of explaining
in the book is why so many people think
there's a liberal media when it's
obvious that there isn't one or aren't
one it's plural noun which is actually
important to remember and that's a
historical story that it's sort of
buried inside the book I don't do a good
job of it's there if you read it and
you're thinking about it but I don't
ever I didn't figure out how to tell it
because the book is not constructed in
it in a historical narrative I didn't
figure out how to weight a way to
explain this but they're one of the the
people who think that they're that the
media are liberal are not necessarily
crazy or dishonest some of them are and
some of them are but they are they are
behind the
times in there was a liberal media the
media were liberal for a long time in
1949 1950 Lionel trilling who was some
along with Edmund Wilson probably the
most important American literary critic
of the past half century wrote a sort of
manifesto he didn't mean it to be a
manifesto but it became a manifesto
called the liberal imagination which was
an essay published in 1949 in a title of
a book published in 1950 and trillings
primary concern in this essay was that
because there was no conservative
intellectual tradition in the United
States that liberalism was in danger of
sort of disappearing into the ether it
was going it was going so flax it and so
boring and so for lack of competition
you know the way you would if like you
were the Yankees in the 1950s and there
was nobody to play you just wouldn't you
wouldn't play your best he wouldn't be
good in liberal liberalism would cease
to develop and this was his primary
concern he he was a liberal whose
biggest worry was that conservatism was
too weak and it would eventually hurt
liberalism and right around the same
time Arthur Schlesinger jr. who at this
point in his life was more of a
publicist than a intellectual or
historian but he wrote a book posted I
believe in 1948 called the vital Center
which actually reads much better today
in a post called warrior than it did in
the Cold War would use what he wrote it
for but again this book was about the
problems facing liberalism and again
there were no conservatives in this book
it was about the threat of Stalinism and
how liberals had to be tough more tough
minded about Stalinism than they were he
was primarily I think addressing himself
to the readers of the nation in the New
Republic which were too soft on Soviet
Union in his view now I think in the 50s
and the 60s and for a while later the
critique that you hear about the about
the liberal media today was entirely
true
that liberals the liberal media had no
respect for conservative ideas had no
respect for conservative culture looked
with contempt upon the sort of everyday
lives of people who are sort of
naturally conservative this hasn't this
has an interesting historical twist just
about the only person I profile in any
length in the book is Richard Mellon
Scaife and I don't do it I only do it
cuz he's really so interesting he's an
amazing guy and I have to be actually
careful what I say about him since we're
on c-span and if the lawyers took out a
lot of that stuff well that was about
scape but he's really interesting he he
he his entire family were kind of
drunken louts his his his both of his
parents were drunks and his his siblings
were drunks and he was a drunken he was
kicked out of Yale for rolling a barrel
a keg barrel over the legs of some kid
on stairs and paralyzed the guy for life
and then he ended up graduating from the
University of Pittsburgh I think might
have been Carnegie Mellon but it
whatever it was his father was the
chairman of the board of trustees and
Scafe spent his whole life doing nothing
exactly as his father did and just being
sort of a miserable person with millions
of dollars or hundreds of millions of
dollars until 1964 when he was I guess
in his late thirties I'm not sure about
that but I'm guessing I don't remember
exactly when he was born and he met
Barry Goldwater and Barry Goldwater had
gotten the Republican nomination for
president and Scafe had his own set of
planes and stuff and a lot of money and
so he found sort of meaning to his life
flying Barry Goldwater around the
country while Goldwater campaign for
president and this was very thrilling
for escapes because his friend his new
friend his new best friend Barry was
going to be the president and you know
that's that's fun for people
particularly people who don't know what
to do with themselves and then you know
one day November whatever was
Scafe wakes up and not only is buried
not the president but he's a national
laughingstock and all of the big names
in the media are writing not all him but
a number of big names in the media like
Schlesinger and Scotty arrested at the
Times and I think Joe al-safa the post
and Herald Tribune are basically saying
that Barry Goldwater has demonstrated
that conservatism in the United States
is over that the movement is finished
that you can just throw it out in the
Republican Party if it ever wants to
have any hope of being a national party
again has to basically move to the left
of the Democratic Party civil rights was
a big opening cause back then remember
the Democrats were an anti they were the
anti civil rights party in the
Republicans were the northern problems
were better on on that issue so Scaife
had this blinding insight which is a
genuine insight and no one I can't
really locate anyone having had it
before him so it's weird that he was you
know this very oddball loser his whole
life but he he he had this interesting
moment of genius and that was that there
would never be a genuinely conservative
president or a genuine conservative
politics in this country so long as the
intellectual class treated these ideas
with contempt which they did so instead
of funding politicians he didn't
entirely stop funding politicians the
first time people ever heard his name in
this country was when he was some it was
revealed that in order to avoid the gift
taxes he wrote Richard Nixon 3,000 I
mean 333 checks for $3,000 each because
over $3,000 he had to pay gift tax and
he thought he could get away with
writing it 300 times and the IRS would
have noticed but anyway he he realized
that the thing to do was not to fund
politicians it was to fund ideas it was
to fund it was to create his own media
and and so he just started throwing
money around in an incredibly profitable
a to anybody who wanted it for whatever
they wanted it as long as it was
furthering this larger agenda he wasn't
very particular about how they did it he
would fund think tanks he gave millions
and millions of dollars to the hair
Foundation and to the Hoover Institute
into the American Enterprise Institute
but he would also fund newspapers and
startups and legal organizations and
anti media organizations like accuracy
and media which is to accuracy and media
what the Holy Roman Empire was to
holiness Roman Empire Ennis um every
time I say that I get a lot of mail from
reader of on so I hope that'll happen
again here and so between 1964 and
1978-79 when these organizations started
becoming mature the political landscape
became to be transformed by them because
on the one hand the media had a whole
reporters had a whole new set of sources
to go to that they didn't have before
before you had to go to the Brookings
Institute or the Carnegie Endowment now
you had all these other guys to go to
who were forming their beliefs based on
their conservative audit conservative
ideology rather than sort of reining to
bureaucratic technocratic ideology oh
the fifties and sixties and and on the
other hand he created an alternative
media and that it's not just escaped
escapes
led the way almost as important as Scafe
was an alliance that was forged in the
70s by the neoconservative The Godfather
of neoconservatism Irving Kristol and
Robert Bartley who retired last year
after 29 years as editorial page era The
Wall Street Journal and crystal had a
similar insight two escapes although he
had it much later with where but his his
insight was not so much on the
conservatism side it was on the
corporate side he decided that the the
new class as he called it of journalists
and educators and some lawyers and
certainly the media were hostile to
capitalism that the 60s movement that
the SDS had basically changed his
initials to ABC NBC and CBS and that the
only way for for businesses to be
successful or to grow in the future of
the United States to be strong was for
businesses to start ponying up millions
of dollars to fight this new class
in the Battle of ideas this ideas have
consequences and so with Scaife and his
fellow billionaires like korres and
later sung-yueng moon and crystal and
this enormous resources of corporate
america the net result was this
formation of this entirely alternative
structure of media that didn't exist
before and the media again it had these
two effects on the one hand it
infiltrated the mainstream media because
the mainstream media was drawing on on
their sources they did they knew how to
play the game they could speak the right
language and they could appear on TV or
give the quote to the reporter that the
quote that the reporter needed but on
the other hand they also created this
entirely self-contained world which he
now see quite openly that from The Wall
Street Journal editorial page to Fox
News to the Washington Times in the New
York Post and the American Spectator and
the Weekly Standard the New York Sun
formed recently and this alternative
media structure has had an enormous
gravitational pull on the mainstream
media structure so that now when you
organize a debate in American politics
about most things and about everything
about most things you have two sides you
have the mainstream view which has grown
increasingly conservative because of
this gravitational pull and you have the
far-right which was organized for
exactly this purpose so for instance I
was on I was on the radio show in San
Francisco with this guy Ron Owens the
top radio show in San Frisco guys
slightly beat he beats Rush and he's
considered a liberal but he's only
liberal in the world of talk radio which
has approximately the same ideological
diversity that Stalin and Soviet Union
had in 1934 maybe not quite as much and
we were talking about coverage in the
Middle East and he says and he said to
me well you know Fox is a conservative
and CNN is the liberal well Fox is a
conservative but that doesn't make CNN
and liberal what the conservatives have
done enormously effectively and this is
exactly what Scafe had in mind although
I bet you he couldn't have articulate it
at a time is that they became two sides
conservative and not conservative those
that those became the poll polls with
debate because the
are so clever at this nomenclature
they've named the other side liberal so
that in fact there is no real liberal
allowed in the room I mean if you if
you're if Fox is a conservative and CNN
is liberal there aren't really any
liberals there now whenever I make try
to make this point on on cable TV or
talk radio I don't I don't get that far
with it really but they always say to me
well fine and dandy but are you really
denying mr. Alterman that reporters are
liberal sometimes I say I don't know and
that's like the nastiest thing I can say
to them because if you say you don't
know on talk radio the entire universe
implodes it's like pressing the ejector
button on Rush Limbaugh and cousin but
in fact on you know I I can I can sort
of take apart and I do in the book now
and particularly on the website where
other people have done it for me but I
put it up on the website in the appendix
the appendices of this book are only on
the website which I'll tell my friends
and c-span is at dub dub dub
what liberal Mediacom and actually
that's where I have these wonderful
appendices by other people Geoffrey
nunberg of Stanford and by the the folks
at taps which is the American prospects
weblog which take apart and Coulter and
bernard goldberg point by point i'm just
throwing that out there in case you care
about that kind of thing but um where
was i oh liberalism and and journalists
well yeah it's true that most elite
journalists are very much see the world
the same way on social issues i you know
my friends are a lot of my friends are
journalists i go to parties with
journalists i live where a lot of
journalists live and I admit that I
don't and I'm entirely search now I
don't think I know anybody who is not
pro-choice who is not pro gay marriage
who was not pro-gun control who is not
pro campaign-finance maybe they are
personally but even if they are
personally they don't believe in
imposing that view on the rest of the
country so there is very there's a very
monochromatic view of the world on
social issues among the elite journalist
I
that even though the research that they
used to defend that doesn't really
demonstrate it but it seems true to me
and it's kind of dumb to argue about at
the same time on economic issues
journalists are to the right these same
elite journalists are to the right of
the country this is in part a friend of
mine has a theory this is in part
because you can't export a journalist
job to Vietnam they don't have to worry
about that so they have no sympathy at
all for they the fair trade argument
over the free trader but it's not just
free trade it's Medicare its Social
Security it's all forms of its education
it's all forms of entitlement programs
and social service programs that
middle-class people depend on but that
upper middle class people do not like
for instance in large measure public
education at least in places like New
York and Washington and on the social
side there's this enormous structure of
a right wing it's not a conspiracy
because it's right there you can see it
but it's this right wing superstructure
that will pounce on your face if you
ever allow yourself to give voice to any
of your biases so it's a bad idea to try
and slant your article against the the
pro-life people see saying pro-life
they've taught journalists to say
pro-life rather than anti-abortion and
that's fine I think they should but
nobody very few people make that mistake
anymore if you say anti-abortion you get
a lot of email and your editor thinks
you're a pain in the ass and it's just
better to avoid it and I said and I
think I didn't give you the figure but
you know when Scafe had his conversion
had his moment of light I'm guessing I
don't know the figures I'm guessing they
were probably fewer than two dozen
significant conservative organizations
in the country and maybe half a dozen to
a dozen of them in Washington total when
Ronald Reagan was elected president
there were about a hundred when George
Bush was selected president oh two years
ago there were over 300 in Washington
alone and these are just the ones listed
in the Heritage Foundation's guide to
conservative groups so maybe there were
more but there were at least three
hundred of which
Scafe funded 113 by himself meant not by
himself but 113 of those groups had
gotten money from escapes so he's
incredibly important figure and in our
recent history but anyway so on this
question of social liberalism I do think
that conservatives have a point that
their views are looked upon with
derision and to some degree contempt by
the elite media and that's actually in
my view what they're really reacting to
that's what makes them so crazy that's
what makes them so angry they're so
they're furious about Dan Rather and Tom
Brokaw and Peter Jennings and I'm
telling you it's it's almost sexual you
hear it so often on talk radio and I
think it's because they're there
correctly perceiving that the peep the
class of people who these anchors
represent really don't have any
understanding whatsoever and possibly
even have contempt for and I'm not
saying these three individuals do but
the general class have contempt for it
the fundamental beliefs of these people
on social issues which are the most
important things in their life now that
doesn't show up in the coverage accepted
anymore very much it does occasionally
there's bias and almost everything you
can't get rid of it doesn't show very
much but just as often I would argue you
you get journalists bending over
backwards in the other direction because
they've been made aware of it I had
lunch today with a wonderful journalist
David Shaw of the LA Times and he wrote
a story I heard a series of stories that
some of you might have read in 1990 a
long time ago about press coverage of
abortion where he demonstrated to any
fair-minded person that the media had
been unfair to opponents of abortion and
he won a Pulitzer Prize for it he was
honored by the industry and actually the
abortion coverage changed a great deal
because of this series people realized
that there was something wrong and they
had a professional ethos to which they
wanted to live up to trying to achieve
objectivity even though they couldn't
ever fully achieve it and and now I
don't think abortion people are pro-life
people are really that angry about the
coverage the issue receives even though
they're not any happier about the way
they are see now on economic issues it's
it's this situation is not the case
the exact opposite because as I said if
you look at opinion surveys on these
fundamental issues like what do you do
about social security what did you about
Medicare what do about patient's Bill of
Rights what do you do about taxes
journalists are to the right of the
public the general public is to the left
on the Democratic Party on most of these
issues if you look at the survey data
but there's no structure at all pushing
the journalists to abandon their
prejudices on these issues in fact they
work for these enormous corporate
conglomerates of which we're down to six
now that that push them further in this
direction because it's really stupid if
you're if you work in a an empire like
AOL Time Warner or if you're laboring in
in some way or in the in the GE NBC
house to make trouble for the parent
company and when they own hundreds of
companies at once it's very easy to make
trouble for them you have to be really
careful not to and you have to watch
what you say all the time there's all
kinds of potential conflicts of interest
that can arise and the best thing to do
is just to sort of write it as as
saccharin as you can to not offend
anyone and if you think about the
economic coverage we get think about the
coverage of the 90s you know where
people like Jack Welch and Bernie Evers
and and God forbid Ken Lay we're treated
like superheroes literally as comic book
figures that's not even the worst part
of it you know that's that's bad enough
we can make fun of that now you know
that these people aren't covers of
magazines literally dressed as
superheroes that happens it's I talked
about in the book but if you think about
the way business reporting is structured
it's about business it's about stock
prices it's not about the conditions
that the workers are facing it's not
about whether or not the right of or the
right the right to organize is being
decimated it's not about the increasing
gap between rich and poor it's not about
whether or not if you labor on a to make
a Harvard cap in Vietnam that sells for
$17 in the Harvard co-op you don't make
the dollar thirty five a day you need to
feed your family of four which
those are actual figures I believe might
be 35 cents a day might be a dollar 35
day in any case you don't make enough
money to feed a family of four in
Vietnam if you have a full-time job
making a Harvard cap that sells for $17
on the call you know they're certainly
not environmental reporting in business
it's a stock price how did the market
you today is this company successful is
it is these are this is a conservative
definition it's a right-wing definition
of what businesses the the people
involved in that corporation are merely
inputs in that in that story they're not
humans you move the job to Mexico or
Vietnam you're reducing the cost of your
inputs the fact that somebody loses
their job or that a community is turned
into a ghost town doesn't enter into it
you'll never see that that's a separate
story I mean even on NPR the great
boogeyman of of the conservative
movement you have to wait a very long
time before you hear of a program called
labor watts
right you're gonna hear market watch if
you watch PBS you're gonna see Lou
Rukeyser well is he still honored he see
the guy he's going to move to CNBC
whatever you're gonna see that show
about the market on Friday night after
Bill Moyers or before Bill Moyers um
but unless you happen to watch Bill
Moyers you're not gonna see a show
that's about workers and you know boys
just not gonna do it every week he's got
other things he's got to do as the only
liberal in anywhere on broadcast
television
all right I'll close up in a minute but
you see I think you see why I'm trying
to explain is why on the one hand is the
conservative is the media why I think
the media is conservative on the one
hand a lot of the definitions are
conservative and most of the motivations
are conservative on the other hand well
I'm gonna have a few hands here that's
and when I talk about that I'm
specifically addressing the conservative
argument which is about so-called
objective reporting because they don't
ever like to talk about opinion
reporting which even if you leave out
talk radio it's still entirely dominated
on the right talk radio
we talked about know cuz Bill O'Reilly
is genuinely a liberal on American talk
radio
it's not a joke supposed to laugh that's
how people would think it was a joke and
then I would say no it's not a joke
thank you but on on on cable TV on the
pundit ah cracy there are there's phil
donahue who's whose job we keep hearing
is in danger there's no there's no book
there's no liberal who's got his or her
own show there's lots of conservatives
got their own show
the only liberals who were allowed on
cable TV regularly are liberals who are
playing liberals and most of them
Carville and and Begala
accepted most of them are sort of
punching bag type liberals there are the
punching bag type liberals or they're
liberals in this incredibly narrow
definition of inside the beltway
liberals which is a liberal who you know
I'm a liberal but I agree with with with
George Bush on this or I mean it's it's
it's it's uh that the word has lost a
lot of its meaning over the past twenty
years they're good people and they
honestly believe what they believe but
it's such a the playing fields become so
narrow that it's it's it's nonsensical
to use the word liberal in a lot of
those cases on broadcast TV which is
where they're really big stakes are for
played for talking about this with David
at lunch today
the only people I can think of off the
top of my head who are who are
encouraged to give their opinions on
broadcast TV are George Will and John
Stossel both on ABC both rabid
conservatives if someone can think of
somebody else let me know so hmm I can't
hear you yeah it's a broadcast TV that's
not that's not TV
that's our is radio so on the opinion
side there can be I don't see how you
can even argue it and on the on the
straight reporting side well it's it's
complicated by the fact that reporters
themselves are largely social liberals
but it ends up having very little
meaning in the reporting and in to me
it's more than outweighed by the
economic biases which is really what I
what I'm more interested in and social
issues if George Bush tried to try to
charge Bush appointed people who tried
to over
row v Wade if he tried to in try to turn
back the clock on social gains that the
countries made he would be out of office
the country wouldn't stand for that but
he can get away with almost anything on
the economic side because there's
there's really no opposition to speak of
except for a few print colonists and if
you notice we have a lot of good liberal
print columnist none of them are on
television regularly not one think of
all the conservative columns who are
both in in the Washington Post say and
on CNN or on McLaughlin or so for
there's not one who among the Liberals
so I I understand why conservatives
complain about a liberal media there are
two reasons one is is that they're
inferring a genuine feeling of
misunderstanding lack of understanding
bordering on contempt for them by much
of the media class and to me it's
unfortunate that exists and it's
unfortunate that it's manipulated and by
right-wing forces that do not in my view
have these people's interests in mind at
all and the second reason that
conservatives do this so often is that
it was true for a long time it was true
I would say up until about 1978 1980 and
as a technique it turned out to be so
damn effective they couldn't give it up
I mean why should they it works there's
a quote at the very beginning of the
book which again everybody here should
buy it but on c-span you can read it the
first chapter on on the website at what
liberal Mediacom there's a quote from
the former chairman of the Republican
Party a man named rich Bondi says yeah
of course we talk about the liberal
media all the time it's called working
the rest and it works well working the
refs in you know in a basketball game if
you scream at the ref a lot and you act
like you're incredibly hurt over how
unfair he's been treating you for the
entire game he's quite likely to give
you the benefit of that whenever he can
so either to make it up to you because
he feels bad or to shut you up because
you're a pain in the ass and
conservatives are journalists feel bad
rather easily and conservatives are
really good at making themselves into
effective pains in the asses I wish
would do a better job I read a really
scary statistic in the New York Times
business page a few months ago you know
that page that they run on Mondays we're
like they have the movie grosses and and
software buys and stuff well sometimes
they have this statistic called
stickiness for websites which as I
understand it means how long you spend
at the website that you're on the
website some of you may have heard of it
Free Republic com
it's a very conservative website it's a
place where say on the day that Paul
wellstones plane went down you'll find
people saying gia which Teddy Kennedy
had been on that plane and it's also
during this website people were posting
and during the Florida crisis people
were posting the names and addresses and
phone numbers of the Florida Supreme
Court justices so people to go to their
houses and yell and scream at them and
who knows what else
well the stickiness of Free Republic com
as I call it and and I may be slightly
off in my recollection was about five
hours and twenty minutes for each visit
so it's very hard to compute with that
these people are at this website
hundreds of thousands of people that
describe sites are five hours at a time
and what they're doing is they're
learning stuff on the website and
they're emailing their congressmen
they're emailing the media they're
writing letters they're organizing
demonstrations free Republic was very
important at getting all those people
down all those Republicans down to
Florida to shut down account in
miami-dade which in the book I traced to
the real is one of the it's you can
trace that moment to George Bush being
in the White House which I think turns
out you know none of us could've bricked
it turns out to be a historic turning
point in this country's history for for
absolutely horrible reasons and I guess
we'll talk about that in question and
answers but I guess what the thought I
want to leave you with is that
everything here I'm talking about none
of it has done in the none of it is done
privately none of us done conspiratorial
none of it's done in backroom hillary
clinton did an enormous disservice to
liberalism when she talked about a vast
right-wing conspiracy
not a conspiracy you can see it you can
go on their TV sessions you can read
their I bet they should it's all there
but it's effective the the fact that the
media are more conservative than they
are liberal and more favorable to
Republican presidential candidates than
they are to Democratic president catus
is the same it's due to the exact same
forces that the country is got
Republican to house the Republican
Senate and a Republican president even
though as I said opinion polls are
basically to the left of the mainstream
of the Democratic Party there they're no
different than they are in Europe where
genuinely left-wing parties are elected
but it's a reflection of the fact that
conservatives are really dedicated
they're really strategic they're patient
they cooperate with each other you know
when when the Christian Coalition Chris
proposed is an incredibly impressive
organization I want you to just leave
you with these two with these two points
about them 1994 when Newt Gingrich want
to take over Congress he met with Ralph
Reed and he explained to him that he
wanted to mail out copies of the
contract on America the contract in
America it didn't address any of the
Christian coalition's issues it I don't
even think it had the word God in it
maybe it did in a in a in a very
tangential way but Gingrich understood
that these social issues are not the
issues where they have the country
behind them so he showed it to read and
read sent out at least a million of
these of these contracts with America to
his followers I think it's more than
million but since we're on TV I want to
get to figure I want to be conservative
about the figure even though it didn't
address anything that he cared about
okay Reid made a strategic decision that
he would he and his followers would be
better off with their guys in power and
they can have the fight later no it's
better to fight with the guy who's in
power and get a half a loaf then fight
when you're out of power and get half of
nothing so I mean think about if any of
you are parts of any liberal
organizations think about imagine a
liberal organization doing this saying
okay you're not mentioning any of my
issues you're not talking about what I
care about but I'm
to fund your operation because I see in
a long-term strategic goal of mine it's
inconceivable liberal organization
wouldn't do it if they had the wrong
order of the words okay I can't agree on
anything now the other thing the other
genius of the of the Christian Coalition
is that they took over the Republican
Party it's a it's a it's a far
right-wing party who's the Attorney
General he's a Christian Coalition kind
of guy the thing about my book that I
saw a that I have to toot my own
proverbial horn here is that you can
disagree with my book but there the
evidence is there their footnotes are
there you can check it ok you can see
you can even if you think that I'm
putting the wrong slant on it that I
don't understand the way the world works
that you know I'm a liberal idiot you
can still check the evidence and see
whether or not you think the cases the
the other books the two main
conservative books that have sold
probably combined a million copies
between them there's no checking them
Goldberg's book bias there no footnotes
there's no research he doesn't believe
in research he said it on c-span someone
said how can you defend this notion that
liberals are labeled all the time that
conservatives always labels conservative
and liberals are never netlabels
conservative where is your data and he
said I have no data I didn't want this
book to be all social science II so
Geoffrey nunberg ran the numbers and
found no in fact the opposite is true
and here's the weird thing all just
about all journalists believe goldberg
it's not true it's false in fact Ted
Kennedy gets called liberal a little bit
more often than Orrin Hatch gets called
conservative Larry tribe gets called
liberal a little bit more often than
Robert Bork gets called conservative
even broader Streisand gets called
liberal a little bit more often than
Charlton Heston gets called conserve
according to the data that you can check
at double what liberal media calm in
appendix one or two and yet all of the
reviews of Coburn's book which basically
said this is a silly book that's all
about how much goldberg hates dan Rather
nevertheless embraced this port even the
review in Columbia Journalism Review by
the Dean of Columbia Journalism school
said this book is on solid ground when
he makes this point it's false this
liberal media myth has been involved by
liberals and by the media and that's one
of the main reasons I wrote this book
that and to put my daughter through
college
so help me out here people sir do you
believe that web logs are an effective
way for progressives to work the refs
yes that's what they're good for
actually I didn't deal much with web
logs in the book because the Trent Lott
affair hadn't happened and most of the
web logs that had had any effect on
politics were web logs by people who had
independent journalist reputations to
start out with like Josh marshal
Mickey cows Andy Sullivan and I suppose
me we're probably the four that's known
journalists who had web logs or had sort
of professional web logs so to the
degree that any of any of our web logs
had any effect it was I think based on
whatever reputation we had from our non
weblog work but with the with a lot
thing the story was dying in the
mainstream media and these incredibly
energetic people in fact Josh Marshall
was one but the other one is this
anonymous guy who named Atrios and I
don't know who he is even though I
sometimes correspond with the same thing
with media [ __ ] I write to them they
write me back and I don't know who they
are but they their information is good
they're you know they're pros this
little interesting but their information
is generally good and they had it they
kept that story going they sort of
embarrassed the mainstream media this
atreus guy kept finding documents from
trend lots past that they had to go back
to forget it
and Trent Lott ended up out of power but
there's two there's two points I always
want to make about Trent Lott that I
don't want people to get too excited
about getting rid of Trent Lott in terms
of that it disproves the fact that
there's a liberal media on the one hand
the two points first is is that the
media really took an interest in that
story because conservatives we're
beating up on Trent Lott William Kristol
to his credit when he got a phone call
saying
did you hear what Trent Lott said he
didn't ignore it the way everyone who
from the so-called liberal media who saw
it did he said my god that's really
appalling somebody should remind lot
he's that the Republican Party is the
party of Lincoln and that that's what
gave the story legs that comment the
second thing is
Trent Lott is gone so what what
difference does it make
they got a better guy there now same
policies nicer face didn't win anything
at all got your eye off the ball
conservatives keep their eye on the ball
liberals take their eye off the ball
media takes their eye off the ball
because the media made this an enormous
story and it was about nothing but
personalities Pickering was appointed 15
minutes after Trent Lott lost his
majority leadership that's a damn sight
more important than who the majority
leader is they definitely have a chance
The Situation's completely fluid Bush is
taking an enormous risk with this war
there's a million different ways that
could go wrong the the the the
nomination is definitely worth having no
I won't I won't speculate on who's gonna
get it oh I'll answer your question
because I don't want to be a dick
worried about but I want to make it
clear that I want to make clear that
what I'm saying is this is who I think
would get it today but anything could
happen between now and then so I don't
know who's gonna get it then if
everybody had to vote today who would
vote I think you'd get a carry Edwards
ticket and if you want to be an a if you
want to be an aficionado the way to be
cool is to lose Edwards and put in
Wesley Clark that's how you sound really
smart because Wesley Clark is like he's
a southerner he's got military
credentials he's really he's really um
authentic and he's like sort of the
smart money person to look really smart
when you make a prediction like Wesley
Clark is gonna be the vice president II
the only people who remembered are the
people who made it you know if it
happens so you get to look like a genius
and nobody remembers that you said it if
it turns out to be silly um plus I think
Wesley Clark is Jewish or mostly it's
profiled in the foreword so that makes
him Jewish no really they don't profile
you if you're not cute so so it's
probably right now it looks to be Cary
Edwards it's hard to understand how the
process the elect Democrats elect
nomination process so anti-democratic
it's all about raising money because the
whole thing is over by March 6th so it's
fair good
be very hard for a McCain tot figure to
emerge and challenge who's ever winning
an organization and turnout and money
and that very much looks like Kerry
today
I think Gebhardt is a thing of the past
I think Lieberman has no support at all
except for the DLC in Florida and he
might lose Florida Bob Graham and
everything's coming up roses for Kerry
assuming he stays healthy I guess the
distinguished mr. Goldberg the the op-ed
pages of the major papers today today's
tend to slant one way or the other or
any noticeably better in your view I
think the op-ed pages are are I think
the print pundit talker see is pretty
close to even in terms of politics
I mean it's significant that so many of
the conservatives are on television the
entire Wall Street Journal editorial
page was on television for a while and
none of the Liberals are not one liberal
amongst those the collection of very
good writers on on many these pages LA
Times New York Times if you were on The
Washington Post and a number of
syndicated people actually it's not
fewer in the Washington Post Richard
Cohen and EJ Dionne are as good as
anyone writing we just probably lost the
most eloquent op-ed writer on the
liberal side which is Frank Rich just
because the New York Times is not a
liberal conspiracy the way the
Republicans say it is and they wanted
him to do culture and they made him an
offer he couldn't refuse but I do think
that to answer your question I do think
that the Conservatives are a lot more
conservative in the liberals are liberal
I do think the ferocity oftentimes near
hysteria of the Wall Street Journal
editorial page has no and at and now
analogous position on the liberal side
if it's if it's the New York Times
versus The Wall Street Journal in a
fight I I'm betting on The Wall Street
Journal I want my money on those those
guys know how to fight they know how to
play dirty the liberals are too
high-minded and and they're much too
interested in seeing I mean I've
supported I try to do it myself but it's
not that they don't Grover Norquist is
quoted in this book
conservative journalists see themselves
as part that self-consciousness part of
a movement whereas liberal journalists
and liberal editorial writers see
themselves as explaining the world in a
fair-minded way by and large yeah I say
in the book too you know the CNBC used
to have used to convene every Friday
night The Wall Street Journal editorial
page to discuss news as if that were an
unbiased few if that was just just
happened to be the guys that were in the
studio at the time and I was trying to
think of how of how liberal you would
have to get to balance the Wall Street
no because I'm not as liberal as they
are conservative and I decided to come
up with a panel to get truly equal time
to the Wall Street Journal editorial
page you'd have to invite Noam Chomsky
Alexander Coburn Fidel Castro and
Vanessa Redgrave voices out there if
there's such a market for it if
especially a lot of the American public
is to the left of the Democratic Party
you know why do people like Rush
Limbaugh get so many so so high so up
jump over high rating and the Fox News
is beating CNN and and why people like
Michael Moore when he gets a TV show on
it that goes nowhere it's like there's
no I mean if there's the audience for it
why don't people you know latch on that
these these things when they're out
there yeah well I don't know I didn't
say I thought that was the market for it
I don't know see nobody's getting angry
saying I don't know that's how we know
we're not on talk radio I'd like to see
tested you know the people who have
tested the talk radio market are not the
right people to have tested it Mario
Cuomo was not any match for Rush
Limbaugh much less Doug Wilder remember
Doug Wilder I mean that's what they
always point to when they say liberal
talk radio fell Cuomo and Doug wild and
Jerry Brown I suppose as well the thing
is is is I thought I made this point but
it's a it said it's I'll make it again
cuz it's a little bit complicated
the country is liberal but the market
the marketplace for the media does not
seem to be Phil Donahue's show is dying
whether maybe it's because it's a bad
show I don't know I don't watch it but
there's no there's no one clamoring for
for a liberal Bill O'Reilly there's no
one let's hope that I mean I hope that
this experiment in liberal talk radio
works out but it's again it's it's a
it's an ideological effort it's not a
market-based effort so the fact is is
that conservatives have organized
themselves into a very effective media
market and liberals have not on that and
and and that's part of the problem so I
like I said I don't think it's a
conspiracy I don't think these these
conglomerates are picking right wingers
I mean they they might be they might
feel more comfortable with them but they
would throw up liberals if they thought
they could make more money with liberals
and they don't and you know I imagine
they're I I imagine they know their
business and that they're right and that
it's until liberals can make nor make
more noise and organize themselves
better and and get the word out better
then this is the way it's gonna be the
first thing I would do in that effort is
buy and read my PO I have any solutions
well no my only solution is everything
fight him on the beach just fight him on
the Seas vitamin the air fighting I like
that organization I don't know that much
about it I gave him my web block a few
times to talk to people because I think
they're good what I like about them I
didn't used to like them because there
was sort of an email organization and
the thing about liberals a lot of
liberals is that they send an email and
then they go back to doing what they're
doing and they feel real good about
themselves and then or they maybe even
they go to demonstration we had him you
know millions of people demonstrating
this weekend the difference between
liberals and conservatives that
conservatives show up on the day after
the demonstration and the day after that
and they send the email every hour or
every day rather than and so what I like
about moveon.org is that Dave
they've moved on actually they're not
just sending emails now they're there
they're presenting bodies they're
sending people to their congressman
there they're organizing genuine points
of pressure and that's what liberals
have to do they have to be a lot more
sophisticated about working the system
and I have to make their presence felt
you know for instance this country the
country's opinion is far more
multilateral list then then our elites
on either Democratic or republican side
it's my view that George Bush never
really cared what the Security Council
thought or what old Europe or new Europe
thought about invading Iraq but George
Bush saw a number back last summer which
said that 27% of Americans would support
a war without the Security Council
ascension and 66% would support it with
it and he was in my view I can't notice
but in my view he didn't want to take
the political risk of going to war and
having something go wrong with so little
support for a unilateral intervention
now and in fact this is just an
interesting aside we've just seen one of
the most intense and most sophisticated
propaganda efforts in the history of
democracy in the past 50 years and that
number is now at 37 38 percent it's not
very good George Bush is not a very
popular president for a wartime
president he's at 54% Bill Clinton on
the day he was impeached was 13% more
popular in George Bush's today you don't
ever hear that in the so-called liberal
media but here's my larger point there
all these conservatives who hate the UN
and they they're always worried about
black helicopters landing in their
backyard and kidnapping their blonde
hair daughters and any any American that
and all these even Democrats have always
got to say no American soldier will ever
serve under a foreign General Bill
Clinton he wanted to have a better
foreign policy than he had but he
couldn't do it politically he had to
fight tooth and nail just to get you
know for the for the intervention in
Kosovo and he didn't get anything like
the support from the Republicans that
the Democrats automatically give to
George Bush in fact Tom DeLay and Dick
Armey wouldn't even pass a resolution
sporting the troops in Kosovo one of
those I support the troops putting out
the war that resolution failed in the
House of Representatives they had the
nerve to risk all kinds of you know
accusations of traitorous nests which no
Democrat would ever at risk but here's
my point uh in a situation of war in
peace that figure of 27% or take the
other figure which is in the high 60s
that didn't want to go to war without
the UN that believes in multilateralism
that supports see you in and thought we
should have been paying our dues the
whole time in war and peace that matters
because Warren peace is such a big thing
you know going to war is prickly this a
war of choice is such a big deal that
the president didn't want to undertake
it without trying to get more support he
may do it anyway but he wanted the
support and everything else it never
matters okay didn't matter when he blew
up Kyoto didn't matter when he pulled us
out of the ICC didn't matter for all
these other treaties that Bush
unilaterally pulled the United States
out of and insulted our allies and so
forth without any care of all the work
that had been put into making them and
that's because the people who are so
multilaterals and so committed to this
view never make their feelings felt they
don't vote on it they don't complain
about it then nobody Jesse Helms could
stop the United States from
participating in many aspects of the UN
for all these years and the Republicans
never paid any political price for it
the Democrats pay a higher political
price for their popular positions much
less their unpopular ones and the
Republicans pay no unpopular no popular
price their gun control is an incredibly
popular cause in this country something
like seventy percent of the country
supports strong gun control laws but I
had a talk with one of course pollsters
after the election I said what would you
do differently if you could do anything
he said I never would say the word gun
guns what it guns what guns are what
killed us why did guns kill them when
it's a 70 percent popular issue because
every single member of the NRA votes and
they all vote on one issue there's
nothing like that on the Democratic side
there's nothing like that on the liberal
side there's no organized sophisticated
political strategy or movement and as
long as that's the case then you can
have
most of the country agreeing with you
and it doesn't make a damn bit of
difference wait I already called on you
no okay so no something that still
sticks in my craw that is you know when
Dukakis was running against George Bush
the father as as soon as Bush called
Dukakis a liberal Dukakis actually just
caved right in instead of saying of
course I'm a liberal how can you how can
any thinking person not be a liberal
yeah well it seems like a lot of
liberals actually must I don't know if
they have guilt about it it's as soon as
they're called liberals they get
blustery and defensive is if it's a
visit they've been told they have tiny
dicks we'll move on we're not going
there arguably one of the most
democratic states right now seems to be
mine arguably oh it seems to be
marginalized I mean the opinion is of
California and it's largely democratic
politics at least as far as electing
Democrats and secondly yeah give me your
opinion on the epiphany of Arianna
Huffington I mean it's not it's not
actually true but but Arianna says it's
true and that's good enough for me no I
had breakfast with Arianna at the four
seasons in Washington cuz I thought she
was very interesting and I wrote her up
in the nation when she was still working
for nuclear when still wearing her and I
said Arianna you believe this we believe
this we believe this come on over the
water's fine nobody else wrote it she
came over she's not throwing me a book
party at that house of hers but she is
doing what I asked her to do now no I
don't know why Arianna did what she did
except she's a very intelligent
thoughtful well-read woman
like this gentleman's friends or even
who California you know this is this
this California thing is indicative of
how weak liberals and Democrats are you
know why cuz great Davis would have lost
the governor's race if the Republicans
had nominated that what's whatever his
name was yeah they they would have lost
if they'd know if they'd had the good
sense to nominate Reardon and and and
here and here you've got the most
democratic the most you know this this
is the one place that is in the
democratic Democrats pocket and they
they they needed the Republicans to be
idiots to hold on to the governorship
you can't always depend you mean it's a
bad strategy to depend on the
Republicans to be idiots they're the the
they're not idiots you know whatever
they are they're not idiots so you can't
you can't have a write off California
cuz it's so big and it's so important
and there's so much money here which is
you know really what the political
system about is about more than boats
but I will say this about California
that bums me out and that is I wish that
um I wish that people from Hollywood
would be more careful when they talk
about politics one of the things that
really hurts liberals is that if you
like live in Iowa you think that the
most important Liberal spokesperson in
America is Barbara Streisand or Alec
Baldwin Martin she's better than I mean
because you know it's good character no
I like Martin Sheen he's a good guy I
don't know Alec Baldwin or Barbra
Streisand and maybe they're great people
for all I know I mean I do know some
Hollywood start so are great people in
fact well I'm I don't want to drop any
names but some of my best friends are
okay anyway but it's a bad thing for
liberals for liberalism to be associated
with Hollywood Hollywood is very much
disconnected from everyday life of
America people and those people did not
understand the kinds of struggles that
people face and I really admire Janeane
Garofalo who gave an interview to Howie
Kurtz recently who's treated rather
critically in the book how he is not
Jeanine where she said you know the
reason that they keep inviting me to go
talk about the war in Iraq is because
they want to trivialize the position if
they really wanted someone I mean she
didn't say this but she's right if they
really wanted to discuss the war on Iraq
they would invite Stanley Hoffman they
would invite Paul Kennedy they would
invite Sir Michael Howard much less you
know people like Noam Chomsky I would
say you like that but they invite Alec
Baldwin or Sean Penn or Janeane Garofalo
and this is part of the this is it's not
like a conspiracy it's just liberals
have have let have let the kept their
eye off the ball and this position has
developed and it would be better if if
people in Hollywood would access to all
these resources did what they were good
at and supported people in politics and
in the media who do what they're good at
and you know you know where to find me
dub dub dub what liberal Mediacom are we
done yet bookstore this is taken a long
time I'm hungry yeah and the piece is
not here yet does anyone else have
anything really smart intelligent that
and also optimistic and encouraging and